gunner wright is returning to voice
isaac clark in the new dead space remake
windows 11 is launching this october
apex legends is completely getting rid
of tap strafing and nba 2k22 has
revealed a ton of new gameplay details
ahead of its launch on september 10th
i'm persia and this is your gamespot
news update
along with revealing some very early
gameplay developers motive studios did
confirm that gunner wright is going to
return to voice isaac clark in the dead
space remake but the dialogue is only
going to happen under certain situations
isaac in dead space from 2008 was voiced
but had no real dialogue with wright
only providing grunts and screams that
changed with dead space 2 and 3 which
saw isaac develop more personality and
an actual voice but isaac won't talk all
the time as a key pillar of dead space
according to motive studios is the
game's isolation
as such there are two instances that
will prompt isaac to speak during the
game when he's spoken to and in a
situation where it would feel weird if
he remained silent per the screenshot
motive studios further outline that
second point and explain which
situations will get isaac talking this
seemingly includes most instances that
require his engineering experience so
for example if the ship needs repair
isaac will talk if something needs to be
blown up isaac will talk if you stumble
on a new objective isaac will talk all
other times though he's gonna remain
silent the studio said the reason for
creating these circumstances is to not
only remain true to the original dead
space by largely maintaining isaac's
silence but also to flesh out and
improve his character a little bit more
dead space doesn't have a release date
just yet but motive studios's rumored
plan is that it's going to launch closer
to the end of 2022
microsoft has announced that windows 11
the next generation of its
industry-leading operating system is
launching on october 5th the new os will
be available for free for all windows 10
users and be released in waves to
customers
some features of windows 11 won't be
ready for launch however most notably
the ability to run android apps natively
on windows 11 will be coming later with
the feature first being offered to
windows insiders after launch windows 11
will also usher in support for direct
storage which will allow dedicated
graphics cards to communicate directly
with storage devices and bypass cpu
communication for faster read
performance akin to xbox series x and
playstation 5. microsoft is also
bringing this to windows 10 in the
future microsoft did revise the
requirements for windows 11 recently
especially in the wake of its early pc
health check app marking many modern
systems as incompatible you can find the
new system requirements over on
gamespot.com
players have discovered many different
techniques that have evolved the
gameplay in apex legends throughout the
seasons with one of the latest being tap
strafing however players are not going
to be able to use it anymore as it's
getting removed from the game
tap strafing in apex legends is a
technique used by mouse and keyboard
players to radically change their
mid-air trajectory and can become even
more drastic with abilities respawn
addressed tap strafing directly in a
twitter post today and said after much
consideration and debate we've decided
to remove tap strafing from apex legends
in patch 10.1
our reasoning it's inaccessible lacks
readability and counterplay and is
exacerbated by movement abilities a more
detailed note about the removal is on
the way but now the community is at odds
once again with controller versus mouse
and keyboard players and high level
players are feeling like their skill
sealing is being lowered but i'm kind of
curious to see what you think are you
happy to see tap shaping go or do you
want it to stay let us know in the
comments
2k sports has released the first
gameplay trailer for nba 2k 22 along
with a deep dive blog post that's
explaining all of the big changes that's
coming to the gameplay this year in
short 2k says its goal for nba 2k 22 was
to deliver faster paced gameplay more
responsive player movement and more
skill based offensive abilities starting
with shooting nba 2k 22 has a number of
changes the most obvious of which is its
new shot meter that now has a
dynamically resizing make window that
expands when you're taking high quality
shots with good shooters but will shrink
when heavily contested using a low rated
shooter or fatigued ultimately rewarding
players for taking smarter opportunities
thanks to a revamped blocking system
defenders will make it more difficult to
finish a play with a flashy dunk there
are also timing meters for alley-oops
and skill dunk attempts but only on new
generation consoles
on defense 2k said it has rebuilt the
shot contest and blocking systems and
thanks to this players will now see
snatch blocks and volleyball spikes that
weren't in previous games while also
delivering some improvements to steals
with a greater focus on specific players
steel attributes
nba 2k 22's september 10th release date
is coming up very soon and there was
even more gameplay details revealed
besides what i already mentioned so if
you want to see the entire list of all
the changes and updates then be sure to
head on over to gamesbot.com
lots of first looks kicking off this
week as we saw welcome to raccoon city
and dead space and tomorrow we are going
to get our first look at new marvel
midnight sun's gameplay right here on
our channel so make sure you come back
thanks so much for watching and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you